over the weekend i tweeted out a thread
on a great article in national affairs
national affairs has this article uh
which basically outlines exactly what is
happening in a macroeconomic situation
it outlines what is bitcoin and then it
argues why america has an opportunity in
front of itself to go ahead and embrace
bitcoin
through that thread mark cuban famous
billionaire the mavs owner and the shark
tank participant went ahead and
responded to the thread and at one point
i had said something like bitcoin
embodies the american ethos and mark
responded with uh a tongue-in-cheek
response that essentially said yes the
american ethos obviously it you yell and
scream at everyone unless they agree
with you and that kicked off an absolute
firestorm i have no doubt that mark knew
exactly what he was doing by kicking the
hornet's nest because bitcoiners began
to bash him and attack him and call him
every name in the book and mark stood
there like an absolute goliath fighting
off everyone by himself
at some point we moved the conversation
from twitter into a twitter spaces and
in there
mark started to share his thoughts now
what was fascinating to me is that most
people in the chat were interested in
attacking him or having some sort of
abrasive conversation explaining to him
why he's wrong on things or telling him
where he missed the mark and if you go
ahead and you just search through
twitter and search mark cuban and
bitcoin you'll see plenty of people
whether they were one of the 15 000
people that were listening live or they
got some sort of uh opinion about it
later and they're calling them an idiot
a fraud a [ __ ] and all these other
things but what's shocking to me is mark
cuban is a bitcoiner
mark cuban owns bitcoin mark cuban said
on multiple occasions both tweets and
also live in the chat of the twitter
spaces i believe bitcoin is the greatest
store of value that's why i own it and
so mark agrees with bitcoiners on the
global store value thesis he believes
not only that it is a store value he
believes it is the best store of value
that's why he owns it now where mark and
the bitcoiners disagree is that mark
sees a low probability of bitcoin
becoming an absolute
global medium of exchange he doesn't say
that it's impossible he just says that
there's lots of challenges and obstacles
to get there and he thinks that the
probability is low now obviously most
bitcoiners think the probability is much
higher than mark does that's okay they
both see a path it's just what is the
probability for that path actually being
realized
and so i think what the most interesting
part of this was
is that mark cuban a billionaire
somebody who's widely respected for his
thoughts on technology who's built
multiple successful companies who
whether we like it or not is one of the
darlings of the media when he says
things the media writes it people who
are not in the investing world or not in
the technology world they look up to
mark and they want to know his opinion
on certain things they see him on shark
tank on abc
he is really important to get
educated on the asset and so rather than
attack people like this we should
actually be embracing them we should be
using this as an education opportunity
as an opportunity to recruit someone to
see the world that we see it and again
you got to listen to be able to do that
and so when i heard mark saying that he
thought bitcoin was the greatest store
of value on the market that made me
happy mark cuban's a bitcoiner there's
nothing wrong with that now
lots of people have problems because
mark also has talked about dogecoin or
he's talking about other assets and
that's okay there's no problem with that
again he explicitly said look i believe
x is going to happen if it doesn't
happen i'll lose money that is what the
free market does and so we got to be
careful of is we can't simply just yell
and scream at people all the time and
say hey you're wrong you're a [ __ ]
you're an idiot you're a fraud you're a
scam that's not how the world works at
some point what we have to realize is
that rather than be abrasive the best
path sometimes is to listen
to hear what somebody is saying and to
simply say you know what here is where
the common ground is we both agree that
bitcoin is the greatest store of value
in the market amazing by the way you
think that there's a low probability
that it could become a medium of
exchange well other people think that
there's a high probability and therefore
let us explain to you why
and then allow him to say i agree or i
disagree and here's why and have a
conversation about it now i fully think
that there's plenty of other people like
this that are going to come into the
market that are going to have opinions
some of them actually are going to be
very uneducated right one of the things
that i think the bitcoin community gets
right is that the critics of bitcoin
frankly aren't that intelligent they're
not that well informed and we're lucky
to have such ridiculously
low
uh prepared critics i love the fact that
they show up and they say things that
were being said back in 2012 that have
been disproved for almost a decade great
they sound like idiots
but
mark cuban and there's others they
actually are very well informed and in
many cases they're not actually a critic
what they're trying to do is have a
rational conversation say hey here's
what i believe this is why i own the
asset i actually see great value in it
but here's the challenges i see here's
the obstacles i see moving forward
sometimes those rational conversations
are really worth it right
yeah i listened to the uh the twitter
spaces you were up late past your
bedtime listen yeah
go ahead i put ranger to bed first and
then yeah uh no but i listened to the
conversation and i thought it was
interesting because first off
regardless of what your opinion is on on
his specific uh kind of overview of of
bitcoin or other cryptos or whatever you
have to respect the fact that he came in
the room with 15 000 people that didn't
like him right and we're gonna set to
argue against them and then second off i
think he was on the treadmill or
something which was pretty funny in its
own right uh but so i i certainly
respect the idea that he came in the
room ready to fight right and that's the
other point of it too is right like you
have to expect someone to be a little uh
when everyone's coming at them you have
to expect them to kind of give you a
little heat back and he certainly did
that but at the same time right like
he's made a lot of comments in the past
that he's contradicted himself he said
certain things about bitcoin that not
necessarily everyone agrees with uh so
there's certainly some history there as
to why people don't trust what he has to
say or trust his opinion or or find his
uh opinion to be uh
intelligent on it right i'd say so i
think there there's some concern there
but ultimately you're right in the
aspect of like he did agree on some
things right he said bitcoin's the
biggest the best store of value in the
world he owns he owns it uh he talked
about dogecoin and some other things but
i think ultimately he agrees on a lot of
things the one main point of contention
that he pushed back on was just seeing
uh bitcoin as a medium of exchange right
and saying hey look uh most of the
bitcoiners believe that we'll get to a
point where there's hundreds of billions
if not billions of people globally that
have adopted bitcoin are using it as a
medium of exchange mark doesn't think
that we'll get that right he just says
that there's better technology there's
better uh kind of projects out there
that might get there quicker or have an
advantage in doing it and he he made
some good points some points that people
obviously didn't agree with but
ultimately i think these are the
conversations that whether you agree
with his points or not are good in
healthy debates right and the idea that
uh anyone who opposes your view you're
gonna kind of just [ __ ] on right is not
smart in my opinion i think you need to
be willing to hear other people's takes
that doesn't mean he's right right you
can you can take it uh kind of step back
and say hey look maybe this is a good
idea maybe it's not but ultimately you
don't want to become the crowd that's
always kind of giving people a hard time
for no reason so i think
those debates are good a lot of people
seem to enjoy there's 15 000 people in
the room uh and whether cuban ends up
being right or not on the global
adoption of bitcoin uh those are the
conversations that we should continue to
have you know just smart people kind of
all in a room talking about the future
of money